and finally numeral in honor of Earth
Day this Wednesday America must go all
out to save a creature that's on the
verge of extinction I'm talking of
course about the Republican politician
who believes in science and with that in
mind tonight we present zombie lice
environmental edition
now how many remember the zombie lied
that I introduced last year it's it's
the label I gave two political
statements that are definitively proven
wrong and yet refused to die the most
zombie lies about the environment are
prefaced by the phrase I am NOT a
scientist Jeb Bush says that so does
Marco Rubio John Bainer says I'm not
qualified to debate science and Rick
Perry says oh my god my hands are gone
wait there anything right there in my
pocket Oh Rick of all the things you
have to worry about people mistaking you
for a scientist should be very far
devilís no Rick you're a legislature
with legislature which means you have to
vote on things like building new
highways even though you're not a dump
truck
Rick also says I don't believe man-made
global warming is settled in science
well they all have some variation on
that one jeb Bush's twist is to say it
is not unanimous among scientists
because that feeds the needs more study
myth that was pioneered by a long
discredited half-wit or as Jeb calls
them my brother
now of course scientific fact is never
unanimous there will always be some
mountain man somewhere with a PhD in
bird calls
who says temperature spikes are caused
by god farts however in 2013 an MIT
professor studied almost 11,000
peer-reviewed articles about climate
change and there were only two
dissenters so yes there is a scientific
community that doubts climate change but
it could fit on a motorcycle or how
about this one let's not panic about the
earth warming in the 70s everyone was
told global cooling was a really big
problem
no not everyone just one article in
Newsweek that for the deniers is the
Dewey defeats Truman of science
the one time in newspaper in 1948
Chicago got an election result wrong and
it proved that journalism is a hoax and
Chicago is just a theory but here's the
thing about that Newsweek story it
didn't say an overwhelming consensus of
scientists thought the earth was cooling
it said a few were floating that theory
or as Mike Huckabee remembers it when I
was in college all the literature at
that time from the scientific community
said we were going to freeze to death
and again by all the literature he means
that one Newsweek article as if Newsweek
is Nostradamus here they are predicting
that M night Shyamalan will be the next
Steven Spielberg he wasn't even the next
Murray Spielberg oh there are so many
echo zombie lies like carbon is good for
you the climate is always changing I
just made a snowball and and of course
Al Gore has a big house trump card but
my favorite is the one that says even
though there may be a scientific
consensus consensuses have been wrong
before
Ted Cruz says just look at Galileo Oh
Ted I worked with Galileo Galileo was a
friend of mine you sir are no Galilei
but as long as you want to look at
Galileo the consensus he disproved was
that the Sun orbits the earth which
wasn't a scientific consensus it was a
Bible myth from caveman he was the
scientist and you know what why am I
getting excited and bothering this was
never about facts to begin with but what
is new is that it's not even about
pandering to voters anymore even half of
Republicans now want this issue dealt
with well good luck because the zombie
lies aren't for the voters they're for
the donors who make their money killing
the planet the question is not why
today's politicians suck more than ever
it's who they're sucking more than
the Koch brothers are in the oil
business and they're pledging almost a
billion dollars in this election for
that kind of money Cruz and Bush and the
rest of them will say anything it's what
their fellow prostitutes in the sex
industry call the girlfriend experience